hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the Attic something happened
some moose man or something went by
there's a head in here but apparently
that's not important enough to warrant
like I can go right through it
that's not porn of war enough dare to go
oh perfect people are coming into my
shop after seeing the Flyers all around
town this is working out nicely as long
as they keep coming in I can continue to
sacrifice them for the blood needed in
the laudanum
at least they die in the name of science
hahahaha I think I have the first
working version of the laudanum I will
lock it away in the cellar just in case
then I will try to recreate it here
alright back to work then what's this I
have three three laudanum which Doc Bell
wash doc anything up here lose man hello
to you too killed those chairs ah what
who's that
whoa that is freaky you're like knocked
back a month Wow what what the heck was
that
what huh what I'm I've never seen that
done before came at the bottom of
staircase but Oh writing on the wall
saying hello the note is written in
blood you should not have got in there
Derek oh go on
for fu Dan do what I want so rebellious
my blood already boils for justice you
had no right
you had no right to Justine okay alright
then break it
Gary check in here okay
screw you guys what huh what room
what room what room are you talking
about what room is you saying we'll just
say that room ah what the hell
hello there's a monster home I'm here oh
that's new I don't remember that art
being hung out there hey guys very
negative I love bones that's also
unusual things are not teeming normal
like
hi what oh hi you there dick [ __ ]
hello whoa what the hell what you doing
hi what are you doing what what are you
doing seriously buddy what's going on
there you're right okay you don't seem
so good i needa get in the room i think
that was in the other way I don't know
hey buddy hello hello
torso dead body I don't remember these
being here Oh key there it is
hey hey where yep but still in this room
hi
goodbye bye bye okay bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye alright bring it on light on
so brave
hello nope joy I got plenty of oil well
shooting out my eyeballs
what door ha ha ha ha Oh what door you
say that door and I'm like what door oh
uh he was like where did it come from
Oh No alright try this again ah like oh
I'm so brave
oh yeah ah man so great a great games
this door how did what how do what are
you talking about that don't save that
door say a specific door use your words
yes it's not a disease and I just need
to go out you could have said that you
could have said that who said that I
assumed it was like oh my god you go to
here hello who broke my window who broke
my window who frogburt which shut up
[ __ ]
ah
okay didn't expect that
okay I'm trying to freak Mac no gonna
happen I'm freaked about unbreakable
ain't nothing will scare me Oh dad what
happened to you who on a leg actually
that's a leg I just threw it on my bed
how am I gonna go sleep tonight that is
wrong oh that's a picture of Justine
yeah it's re good some of my nose huh
alright then maybe you Justine has
something to do with this or something
oh oh I fell screaming through the alien
cityscape dreck clenching the stone key
now I stand with the brothers that's
hard to read hello the note is written
in blood stop Derek you're biting off
more than you can chew if you know
what's good for you you will jump off
this deck and forget about everything
you learned today what what how does
that make me forget that makes me die
alright if you say so dad I'll totally
wait I can't even jump off don't tell
can you do it
sit up Andy fine
what what wait what are you whimpering
at baby oh my baby
oh no hey there bucko what's going on
how you doing
oh and clothes are doing on your face on
so what do I do
god I know no mementos no Mentos check
it out here nope no boo-boo
uh-uh nothing here well maybe that guy's
not there bro oh yeah he busted down the
door that's right
oh look smooth oh it's a dead body okay
there we go oh wow hey where the Fricke
frack did you come from
douche dick Oh didn't even click I'm
expecting a responding Clank you're not
giving me what I need I need auditory
cues cognitive dissonance or something
ah [ __ ] you how did you get through that
door so quickly
ah [ __ ] you I get the chair [ __ ] are you
come at me bro
I didn't even chair don't do anything
anymore
not fair tears used to do something but
now they don't oh oh [ __ ] on this door
oh whatever oh skull turn the box fine
oh what's this then that's all that I
guess I have to find another key hello
hello hello nothing
hello oh so scary why's our grave in a
closet okay we'll get a slap the crew
here to hear what kind of layout in this
house I'm setting in here nothing nope
all right then I'll leaving me many
options
hello library their secret books
secret stuff anything at all ooh what's
this
all right that's freaky thing to have
enough oh oh it's like an ulcer okay
this is a freaky thing to have in a you
know house because you think you would
be like Bernal who's done in the way of
science
what does as the opposite of science
oh it turns science into a cone it's
hilarious
hello what's in it
wait I couldn't get through this door
before oh oh oh oh no oh no Korea Korean
your heads screw you all of you
Kuya Grier lady oh no not you so fine
mmm I got a key to some basement you
don't watch my oil consumption maybe
it's one of these doors that were locked
before probably knew all right then
Sarah is there another way down then I
didn't run into nope not that one
it wasn't this one either because it
just goes back to where I found the key
okay um what the back maybe not remember
thinking anything else like this was
already the leading down area s is
already leading down ah what you already
did that that that already happened
huh I must be in this series I must just
be over looking at or something let me
go back to talk to these ladies these
fine people over here maybe I could
stack up like a chair get over probably
hoop up nope yep
there we go ah oh it already happened
don't do that get out my way it's such a
dick
oh I can make it I'm gonna break the
game any anymore anymore anymore anymore
okay
gimme this one nope oh [ __ ] you chair
I'm sorry I said that chair no I'm not
I'm sorry that you made me feel sorry
come on I can make I can make Oh bring
it back yeah that perfect perfect yeah
no apparently no okay um I wasn't here
oh it was here oh I'm such an idiot
while I look back why why did I look
back why did I look back why why did I
do that why did I do that thing that I
did why did I do that I don't even know
huh okay all right I'm okay okay come on
who's that their oil ten box get not
locked don't block why have so many
doors if they're all gonna be locked not
locked
what door you think you can take me
yeah you're rats screw this what's this
piece of glass saw blades shovel whoa
Hotel what the hell is that okay that
was weird
more oil except gonna run out of oil if
I knock hello
mmm no joke really really you think I
needed to be told that Oh II do think
take me for Dhar I swear I will Jack
slap
Oh door youth door doors I've never done
that before you build door correctly you
ever designed this house is bad well we
got here a note it's done
I got a working version of the potion
and logging in the main storage room
what an accomplishment as it will be the
first thing stored there your
accomplishment is storing something in
the storage room I will now try to
regrade the serum main storage key fan
AB ulis up I'm out of time actually
thank you so much for watching and as
always see you in the next part
bye-bye